let's get more on this from Thomas
Kaplan a congressional correspondent for
the New York Times Tom good morning good
morning
so we've had a few days to digest 140
plus pages how does this Senate bill
compare to the House bill so in broad
strokes it's similar it ends the
requirement that most Americans have
health coverage it makes big cuts to
Medicaid but there were some key
differences it treats pre-existing
conditions a little bit differently that
was a big issue in the health bill
having said that generally we're talking
about the same the same kind of approach
that we saw in the house five senators
are opposed five Republican senators
opposed at this point what are their
objections so it varies a little bit
when the bill came out at first a group
of four senators mostly conservative
some of the most conservative members in
the Senate came out against it their big
objection at least for most of them is
the idea that this bill doesn't go far
enough to repeal Obamacare that's an
issue that is kind of tough to resolve
because many senators don't really want
to repeal all of Obamacare for instance
there are there elements there that are
popular with consumers and if they go
for if they go further they may lose the
moderates on the other exactly that's
sort of the the Box now you have other
issues other people such as Dean Heller
in Nevada that's a state that expanded
Medicaid under the law more than 200,000
people in Nevada have health coverage
because of that provision it's a big
political risk for him if he's going to
support getting rid of that one of the
things that they have to get as the CBO
score which the house did not wait for
is as far as the Senate do we have any
idea what that CBO score might look like
so it's kind of hard to gain this out in
advance but it's probably going to be
somewhat similar just because the bills
are somewhat similar the CBO score for
the house ultimately it was a pretty
tough thing to defend 23 million people
in a decade more people who would not
have health coverage we don't really
know what the Senate report will show
but big questions how many people would
lose coverage also premiums does this
actually bring down premiums in a
meaningful way it keeps saying they want
this to be Affordable Care care that
people can afford I guess that's the
ultimate question does it actually
that right and there are big questions
now what would this do to the insurance
market so for instance would people be
sort of forced into very high deductible
plans that's an issue under the
Affordable Care Act so their overall
cost ends up being more you know that
premium is less Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell wants a vote before the
July 4th recess is he going to be able
to get this bill in a position where it
can pass in that amount of time there's
not a lot of time right now this bill
would not pass so changes need to be
made it's again get back to this issue
of if you make changes to please some of
the most conservative members how do you
then avoid losing some of the more
moderate members including some who have
raised concerns such as susan collins
from maine who you know could end up
being opposed to this even though
they're not out there right now yeah so
there may even more net be negative
votes out there who've not committed and
we'll see what the CBO score if a score
comes back saying you know 20-something
million people would be without coverage
that's an issue for the Senate have said
wait for the Senate has to wait for that
score like the house all right Thomas
Kaplan thanks so much for being well
thank you